hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a full
in-depth breakdown in analysis of
Justice League for those of you who
thought like me maybe this movie was
better than the 41% fresh rating or even
if you thought that was right on the
money there's a lot of interesting stuff
to talk about in this film the visuals
the music the cultural influences the
connections to DC Comics and the subtle
details that made this movie special
CK's special is a word I used to avoid
offending either side of a stupidly
polarized debate what do you think did
it work I'm guessing not boilers ahead
here we go going back through the film
starting with this prologue smartphone
footage of Superman now right away check
out Henry cavils upper lip once half of
you stopped kissing your computer
screens you'll notice this lip looks a
little weird in human even why is that
the case according to reports cavil had
a mustache throughout resuits that he
was legally bound to keep her his
contract for the movie Mission
Impossible 6 so the effects team had to
digitally regenerate his upper lip to
cover the mustache that also tells us
that this prologue was part of reshoots
and probably not intended as the
original opening image of the film that
kind of makes sense the following scene
opens on this grim newspaper headline
reading Superman is dead by comparison
this smartphone footage is more
lighthearted less precious and
aesthetically less cinematic most feels
like something out of Spider Man
homecoming the benefit of opening the
film this way is it kind of cleanses the
palate of the decidedly bleak tone of
the predecessor Batman vs Superman it
reminds us of the inherent kindness and
humor and sure hope that these
characters will be fighting for Superman
hear echoes Jonathan Kent by comparing
hope to car keys easy to lose but if you
look around it's close by but it also
interestingly describes this Kryptonian
symbol of hope as a river something that
winds comes and goes his point is that
the way a river bends so we can't see
around the corner hope is that uncertain
outlook that the waters will still be
calm on the other side and was asked
what is his favorite thing about Earth
and he doesn't answer Henry Cavill
actually speculated what was running
through Superman's mind here the human
capacity to love yeah of course there
would be your answer golden boy let's
move on to Gotham City
this whole opening rooftop scene with
Batman is a nod to the 1989 Tim Burton
Batman opening rooftop scene from the
bat scary silhouette to dangling the
criminal over a Ledge but of course the
deeper connection was Danny Elfman's
music he repurposed his original iconic
Batman score from the 89 film when he
was asked how he
would incorporate the theme Elfman said
that he wanted it to be more subtle the
DNA is there but the themes aren't
necessarily obvious except for one
moment where Joss Whedon said to do the
theme on the nose we went on to say that
he told DC that they have a great
musical heritage that they should be
proud of and that they should keep it
alive referring to his own original
score but also others which will point
out as we go now Batman gets attacked
here by a pair of demon we last saw
these in Batman's nightmare sequence and
Batman vs Superman those are from the
new 52 comics they're the minions of
Darkseid created from past life forms
that he has conquered but when Batman
flies over the Gotham skyline with a
paired demon he passes this sign for
Janus that is for Janus Cosmetics the
company owned by the Batman villain
black masks in the comics slack mask has
also appeared in the Arkham games and is
rumored to be in the DC upcoming movie
you got from City sirens and when the
parademons self-destructs he leaves a
marking of three mother boxes the focal
artifacts of this story in the DC Comics
mother boxes are these like God devices
from apocalypse that's dark sides
hellish homeworld and as they do in the
comics in this movie we see them opening
boom tubes a type of worm hole that
Steppenwolf can travel through moving on
to this opening tidal montage set to the
music of everybody knows by Leonard
Cohen here covered by the Norwegian
singer cig read the lyrics are bitterly
pessimistic describing a bleak prophecy
about the end of the world as we know it
this reflects the world as these
characters know it where the war is over
but the good guys of loss these shots
show us landmarks around the world Notre
Dame and Paris and Tower Bridge in
London all with a black banner in a
silver Superman sigil now this color
scheme matches Superman's casket Batman
vs. Superman which also matches
Superman's a black suit color scheme in
the return of Superman comics and the
doom and gloom doesn't stop there
there's a shot of the Kent farm
foreclosed on by the bank with the crops
withered and dead making it interesting
when the crops appear green and lush
later when Clark returns and there's
this weird metropolis post cover showing
Superman alongside David Bowie and
prince has fallen pop icon's Zack Snyder
actually did a similar thing in the
opening credits of Watchmen infusing
superheroes with real-world celebrities
including hey David Bowie the inclusion
of Prince is also interesting
considering the music of Prince was such
a huge part of the 1989 Tim Burton
Batman to me this is kind of a signal
that the old world of Batman is long
gone Neider also included another edgy
easter egg here when a skinhead
vandalized as a shot
owned by a Muslim woman if you look
closely his hoodie says mega horde
that's mega as in make America great
again Donald Trump's campaign slogan
that has been adopted by a lot of white
supremacist groups and I'm not gonna
touch that one
moving on to London where danny elfman
introduces us to wonder woman by
sampling Hans Zimmer's and junkie excels
great themed open said that he swapped
out the heavy electric guitar sound from
the past time we heard the music with a
grander orchestral sound also there's a
reference to Diana's mythological origin
here and she's standing on old bailey a
statue of the Greek goddess Denis who's
also known as Justitia in Roman
mythology aka Lady Justice and after she
kicked some ass Bruce Wayne tracks down
Aquaman Bruce is seen riding a horse
here which could be a reference to
Batman riding a horse in a Dark Knight
Returns comic also Zack Snyder mentioned
films like the Seven Samurai and The
Magnificent Seven being major influences
on the story of Justice League
now those movies center around an
eclectic team of warriors having to put
their differences aside to fend off a
hostile invader
just like the Justice League do in this
movie perhaps the horse back was a nod
to that influence now I really enjoyed
the way Arthur curry was adapted in this
film but in the ways it hinted at the
characters comic origin and how they
translated him to scream his winter
clothes have an orange color to them a
nod to Aquaman's orange suit in the
comics also Bruce makes this joke you
can talk to fish which is a really good
job to alleviate any fears that this
Aquaman would come up as cheesy as a
version people have in their heads
instead Jason Momoa as Aquaman comes off
as more of a surfer bro with long some
bleach hair and tattoos and speaking of
those tats they were designed to reflect
the moas Polynesian tribal ancestry
known for the tradition of warriors
tattooing their skins with patterns of
shark teeth and spear heads to resemble
armor and convey strength Jeremy Irons
is Alfred returns helping Bruce decode
Lex Luthor's files from Batman vs
Superman and equips this fun line one
misses the days where mom's biggest
concerns were exploding windup pain
now of course this is a reference to the
penguin one of the many villains this
Batman presumably locked away in Arkham
Asylum then we meet Barry Allen the
flash visiting his father Henry in
prison now the officer working the front
desk is actually a cameo this is Mark
McClure aka Jimmy Olsen from the
original Richard Donner Superman films
McClure was originally set to cameo as
the cop that cyborg saves in Metropolis
that we saw in the trailer but when that
scene was cut during resuits they recast
McClure in this scene and I really like
this gag with Barry moving ever so
slightly and pranking this jerk behind
him reminded me a lot of the prank by -
in The Incredibles who took a lot of
inspiration from the character to flash
Barry's father Henry Allen is played by
Billy Crudup
who previously worked with Zack Snyder
as dr. Manhattan and Watchmen in the
comics Barry believes Henry is innocent
in the murder of his mother Nora which
leads them to his career in forensics
just like it does at the end of this
movie in the comics Nora was actually
killed by a time-traveling professor
zoom in the CW series the culprit was
reverse flash that time-travel mystery
is probably gonna play a bigger role in
the Flash's upcoming solo film
flashpoint next we see dr. Silas stone
at STAR Labs part of cyborgs origin in
the comics now Silas is played by Joe
Morton we saw him briefly in Batman vs
Superman but he also played doctor miles
Dyson and T - judgement day he's really
the burger guy had a cast as the
scientist meddling around with some
potentially world-ending technology the
janitor he talks to has the last name of
Jensen in the DC Comics a man named
Raymond Jensen becomes the villain
parasite now you may have been wondering
how this mother box that we saw buried
somewhere in ancient Europe made it to
STAR Labs in America apparently there
was an epilogue seen deleted from Wonder
Woman that explained all this and a
candy was gonna meet with Steve Trevor's
crew in a bar discussing how a very old
and very powerful artifact was
discovered after bombings along the
Belgian front and it needed to be
shipped to America to be kept out of the
wrong hands okay moving on to the
mascara the island of the Amazonians
where we see the arrival of this movies
villain Steppenwolf now in the comics
Steppenwolf is kind of a less memorable
villain he's a general serving under
Darkseid he's also Darkseid's uncle now
in this movie stepping off his voice to
perform to be a motion capture by Ciaran
Hinds aka mance rayder from Game of
Thrones and even were crazy about him as
a villain we actually spent a lot of
time analyzing him in our recent Justice
League review on the need to know so go
check it out I like how Hippolyta
ordered Steppenwolf to be sealed inside
this structure with the Amazonian
smashing out the support beams this
actually reminded me a lot of the
opening scene
x-men apocalypse when apocalypse was
sealed inside a pyramid in the similar
way honestly that was the best part of
that movie but moving on to Diana
explaining to Bruce the mother boxes
ancient history through this epic
flashback now if you look closely there
were a few cameos here most
interestingly a shot of an ancient Green
Lantern bashing parademons with a big
green hammer until getting killed by
Steppenwolf and his power ring zips away
so yeah this obviously wasn't the Hal
Jordan or Jon Stewart Green Lantern's
this was a previously bearer of the role
the fact that he has a cape unlike most
Green Lantern's that we've seen could be
a nod to Alan Scott the very first
incarnation of Green Lantern who did
have a cape either way the appearance of
this dude is setting up the existence of
the Green Lantern Corps an upcoming DCEO
movie in 2020 that will focus on the
larger organization of several different
Green Lantern's also from one woman
there's some other cameos Robin writes
and typey and David Thewlis is Ares but
we also see the old gods Zeus is the one
who drives Steppenwolf back with
lightning from his hands and the archer
goddess with glowing arms is probably
Artemis at the end of this sequence
Bruce bemoans humanity's chances by
saying we act like the Doomsday Clock
has hit the snooze button that would be
another reference by Zack Snyder to
Watchmen which had a recurring Doomsday
Clock image to display how deeply
divided humanity was let's move on to
Bruce meeting Barry the background of
Barry's flight is filled with
interesting details he mentions web
design as a skill and on a shelf yeah
there's a book on XML coding along with
a political biography so in addition to
running fast Barry can also speed read
and process information extremely
quickly so it makes sense that he would
be devouring information constantly he
also has an episode of Rick and Morty
playing on one of his monitors this is
actually the montage where Rick and
summer team up and trained to beat up a
devilish character which is very similar
to what the Justice League do in this
movie even if Rick would probably see
this movie is more like the of
indicators another possible Rick and
Morty reference comes from Aquaman later
my man is the recurring catchphrase of
the mailman on Ricky Morty my man also I
like the detail of Barry hanging his
suit up on a crash-test dummy this
suggests that he may have been testing
the suits durability the way we test car
safety like maybe he's speeding while
carrying this dummy and then just
release him into a brick wall gonna be a
fun deleted scene Barry also jokes that
he knows gorillas sign language and that
could be a reference to the flash
civilian gorilla grodd a super
intelligent telepathic gorilla
also I love Bruce is battering through
from the first time we saw it in the
trailers which yeah seemed a little
premature Bruce wasn't
this was the right Barry Allen like I
started to think how many other Barry's
in Central City got stabbed with
batarangs before Bruce finally found the
one that was fast enough to dodge it and
you can actually use this shot to
determine how fast exactly the flash can
move calculating with the average speed
a human can fling any weapon and the
estimated distance between them this all
goes down in our time of 0.3 4 seconds
which is the average length of time a
human blinks this is literally in the
blink of an eye and crunching that
number with the duration of this throw
in slow-motion this all tells us that
the flash is capable of moving 62 times
faster than normal human speed I also
like how this movie takes into account
how many calories Barry would need to
burn to move that fast
showing him binge eating pizza later
Baylor was also a cutscene that showed
Barry eating 800 hamburgers ok
fast-forwarding bit to Steppenwolf
establishing his base now this is set in
a town in North Russia surrounding an
unsafe irradiated nuclear plant
basically a fictional version of
Chernobyl in Ukraine the designers
actually used real-world locations from
Chernobyl to create the setting this
building that Batman drives through
later is the politia Hotel in Pripyat
that's the now abandoned city outside
Chernobyl creepy ads ferris wheel also
showed up in Stepford oh now it's during
this scene that Steppenwolf mentions his
goal to take his place among the New
Gods and cleanse this world for the
unity with dark side now this instance
is the one mention of the name Darkseid
in Justice League dark side is the
super-powerful cosmic entity from the
comics who takes over worlds and he is
so strong that it takes all of the
Justice League to stand up to him and
even then they usually can only manage
to fend him off that all changes in the
final crisis event when they're finally
able to destroy him but it's a shitstorm
that requires time travel and Superman's
singing to disrupt Darkseid's life force
yeah comics and actually the nightmare
vision from Batman vs Superman could
have been showing that Final Crisis
event that huge Omega symbol is
associated with Darkseid in the comics
and the portal of the flash appeared
through could have been connected to the
time travel of that plot we'll see then
we see JK Simmons as Commissioner Gordon
and the detective who talks with them
about parademon sightings is named
Crispus Allen Christmas Allen is another
character from the DC comics he's a cop
who later becomes the third host of the
supernatural force called Spectre and
when the team begins to assemble there's
a quick shot of a Gotham skyline that
shows a sign for ace chemicals that is
the same chemical plant where the Joker
fell into a vat and became disfigured we
saw both Joker and Harley Quinn
dive into one of these ace vats in
Suicide Squad there's also this badass
shot of Batman meeting Gordon by the
bat-signal and notice the gargoyle that
he's perched on this is the grim reaper
and yes it's a little odd that Gotham PD
would put a statue of death on top of
their building but I guess this is
Gotham also this image is an homage to a
well known cover of the Batman comics
Detective Comics issue 6 8 - and there's
an even deeper connection with this shot
that will bring up later now down in the
tunnels beneath Gotham Harbor I love how
the flash is used in the sequence first
Bruce sets up the Flash's hero arc in
this scene telling him to just save one
person and he'll know what to do next
this gets paid off later in Russia when
Barry's role is to once again prevent
civilian casualties this scene also
introduces us to Danny Elfman's amazing
theme music for the flash a track titled
spark of the flash now this music comes
back later when Barry jump-starts the
mother box Oldman is using this music to
evoke the feeling of what a miracle
sounds like those high string notes
remind me a lot of Don Davis's score for
the matrix that played at the end of the
movie the second neo realized that he
could move faster than a speeding bullet
or I suppose in this case he didn't have
to
when Steppenwolf floods a tunnel aquaman
arrives and redirects the water this
could have been an homage to Jean Grey
at the end of x2 blocking the flood
waters to save the rest of the x-men
afterwards Gordon says this line to
Batman it's good to see you Blaine well
with others again this is interesting
because that hints at Batman's history
as a team player specifically with Robin
Jason Todd or Nightwing Dick Grayson
Batman vs Superman remember suggested
the death of Robin with Superman keeping
Robins vandalized suit with the joke's
on you haha written on it implying Joker
had done this Suicide Squad kinda
confirmed this remember during Harley
Quinn's introduction you can barely make
out that she was quote an accomplice to
the murder of Robin by the way you
probably notice that Aquaman's Trident
is it a true Trident it has five spokes
this Momoa said that it isn't the true
Trident of Neptune that Aquaman wields
in the comics he guess he hasn't yet
written to become king of Atlantis later
on in the Batcave Bruce proposes
resurrecting Superman saying quote even
if there's a fraction of a chance before
getting cut off this is a callback to
his line to Alfred and Batman vs
Superman then fearing Superman is the
threat and if we believe there's even a
1% chance that he is our enemy we have
to take it as the absolute certainty
Barry calls this a pet cemetery scenario
referencing the Stephen King book and
eighties movie adaptation about a cursed
Native American burial ground that
brings the dead loved ones back to life
but evil demonic murderous versions of
themselves
I think this morbid experimentation
eighties connection is why I enjoyed
this section of the movie so much the
flash in cyborg joking while digging up
Clark's remains and disguising
themselves as military personnel
sneaking into the Kryptonian ship it all
has this goofy so crazy it just might
work
vibe that the kids from it her stranger
things would try okay you can't just
break through man back to life it's
almost as bad as feeding a gremlin after
midnight you know cuz of the references
and while Bruce weighs the ethics of
this he admits that Clark was more human
than he is that Clark had a real job in
Hawaii and I like how looking back
Bruce's joke to Barry what are your
superpowers again I'm rich this
gradually evolved into this more
profound realization that his wealth and
seclusion detached him from real
humanity meanwhile kal-el's efforts to
tone down his super heroic nature and
blend in made him relatively more human
a fascinated insight and yet 41 percent
now Superman's resurrection is a major
event from the
these comics there he didn't technically
die he was just depleted of all of his
energy and then he was placed in a
restoration chamber and he came back to
life with some missing abilities and yes
that black and silver suit and this
movie that's implied that he actually
did die and that he was pissed off when
he was brought back now there are two
cool ways here that Justice League
unites Superman with the rest of the DC
Trinity Wonder Woman and Batman first at
France Superman with his own severed
statue head compare this with the two
other times he saw heroes framed with
statutes Wonder Woman is the Lady of
Justice the fairest minded of the group
who seeks the truth that man is the grim
reaper the feared bringer of death and
now Superman is the headless martyr the
scorned scapegoat who gave his life to
end the misdirected societal hatred also
Danny Elfman cleverly samples John
Williams's classic Superman score from
the 1978 movie however Elfman twists
part of the melody into a darker version
[Music]
this dark tone reflects Superman's
momentary descent into a more hostile
antagonistic version of himself I
specifically love the feeling of fear
that this scene inspired when Superman's
angry eye follows Perry as he dashes
past him yeah that's not the kind of
side eye you want to get Aquaman is
actually the first of them to realize
something's off telling the others he's
not all right
the reason Aquaman can tell is according
to Jason Momoa he and Clark actually met
in the past and Manas steel when Clark
nearly drowned after falling off the
burning oil rig apparently Aquaman was
the one to save him so a few callbacks
to Batman vs Superman in the scene first
Superman chokes Batman asking him to you
bleed he's of course calling back Batman
threatening him with that question
before also the big guns that Bruce
calls Alfred for Lois Lane she is the
one weapon that can neutralize Superman
here this also could be a callback to
Batman vs Superman with Bruce hitting
the mysterious advice from the flash or
as he saw it his last time dropping acid
moving on to Lois and Clark on the Kent
farm now the framing of the shot when
Lois walks up behind him is designed to
be an homage to their early encounter of
Man of Steel but with Lois in the
foreground turning to see Clark over her
right shoulder Zack Snyder actually
storyboarded this scene with this in
mind
also notice how Clark is wearing red
flannel in the scene that's a throwback
to his wardrobe in the original Richard
Donner Superman now I really enjoyed
this gag with Aquaman accidentally
touching Diana's lasso of truth and
speaking his mind and confessing how
attractive he is to her this is another
gag from the Justice League comics
except it happens to Green Lantern
moving on to this final battle
Steppenwolf Stara formation causes the
sky to turn red which is another night
of the DC Comics and the events leading
up to the Final Crisis they're called
the crisis on Infinite Earths the first
sign of something bad happening to those
events is the sky turning red this
close-up of Batman's mortar shell
hitting the ground in slow motion
there's also a callback to Batman vs
Superman we start at the end of that
movie when the big guns honored Superman
at his funeral later a Batman swing into
action taking down a few pair of demons
is a nod to his first ever appearance in
the comics on the cover of Detective
Comics issue number 27 when Superman
joins them in the fight against
Steppenwolf he quips I believe in truth
I'm also a big fan of Justice this is a
reference to Superman's classic
catchphrase
truth justice in the American Way
another classic reference comes up when
Superman appears speeding alongside the
flash calling him slowpoke and Barry
responds oh it's on this race of course
is called back in the post-credits scene
but it's an homage to the iconic fastest
man alive comic Superman issue 189 the
flash and Superman speed test came up in
Smallville as well and yeah despite the
debate among fans the flash is totally
faster at least when his powers are
totally developed in this movie he's
still kind of a kid developing his speed
so it makes sense that Superman would be
faster here after saving the family the
flash says to us will you have ski which
seems like a random throwaway joke but
looking deeper into this it's not random
at all Dostoevsky is a famous Russian
writer he wrote crime and punishment a
very long book which knowing Barry speed
reading abilities he probably breezed
through the story focuses on a man who
commits murder to test a theory that
some people are naturally capable to
take life and those people are morally
superior and have the right to kill this
concept was hugely influential on the
philosophies of Friedrich Nietzsche who
reframed the argument with the term
Hubermann which is German for that's
right Superman
so with this joke the flash is
acknowledging the philosophical
inspiration for 20th century comics
superheroes like Superman Batman and
Wonder Woman who some have argued
possess a Nietzsche and moral
superiority that places them above the
laws of men meanwhile cyborgs reverence
is a little less nuanced yeah yeah
booyah is cyborgs catchphrase and Teen
Titans cyborg is so visual basic moving
on from these slam dunk puns to this
closing sequence Bruce Alfred and Diana
returned to the abandoned Wayne Manor
which Bruce plans to furnish with a
round table six chairs and room for more
yeah this is setting up the Hall of
Justice from the Justice League comics
as their base of operations
clearly room for more is hinting at the
rest of the Justice League joining the
fold at some point Green Lantern and
maybe even Martian Manhunter the closing
image of the movie shows Superman
blasting off into the sky the thematic
opposite of Zack Snyder's bleak opening
newspaper headline Superman is dead
this shot fulfills the promise of the
prologue cell phone footage almost
answering the question that the kid
posed as Superman in that moment what is
the best thing about our world our
undying hope for a better one who do you
think is the true hero of Justice League
now I'm gonna go out there and say the
flash he's the most vulnerable making
him braver than the others and as from
Ella's charm ends up saving the movie in
so many ways but I want to know what you
guys think weigh in in the
comment below or tweet me directly at
Eva's and fall into rockstars on Twitter
for updates on our videos like and share
this video and subscribe to new
rockstars for deep analysis of all the
stuff that you love and support this
channel by contributing to us on patreon
big thanks to all of our donors
especially Matthews all of us thanks for
watching guys bye
[Music]